empecemos con las propiedades físicas de
los alcoholes en este caso vamos a
comparar alcoholes con alcanos este
alcano a la izquierda tiene dos carbonos
por lo que es uno
está
a la derecha si quitamos uno de los
hidrógenos y lo reemplazamos con un h
tendremos sal
así que empecemos con puntos de
ebullición el punto de ebullición del
etano es aproximadamente menos 89 grados
celsius y ya que la temperatura ambiente
está alrededor de 20 y 25 grados celsius
la temperatura ambiente es mucho más
elevada que el punto de ebullición del
etano lo que significa que ya hay mucho
ya ha sido transformado en un gas
así que a la presión y temperatura
ambiente el etanol es un gas sin embargo
el etanol tiene un punto de ebullición
mucho más alto alrededor de los 78
grados celsius y una vez más si la
temperatura ambiente está entre 20 y 25
el punto de ebullición del etanol es
mucho más alto que la temperatura
ambiente por lo que a la presión y
temperatura ambiente el etanol es un
líquido no aburrido out
y estas grandes diferencias en puntos de
ebullición entre estas dos moléculas
puede atribuirse a las fuerzas internos
leku lares que están presentes sidoso
leku las de etano están interactuando
las únicas fuerzas inter moleculares que
van a estar uniendo a estas moléculas
serán las fuerzas de dispersión de
london que son las fuerzas internos leku
lares más débiles así que es
relativamente fácil separar dos
moléculas de etano y eso se observa en
el bajo punto de ebullición no se
necesita mucha energía para separarlos
por lo que es fácil para el
transformarse en gas
sin embargo el etanol tiene un punto de
ebullición mucho más alto lo que
significa que es mucho más difícil
separar esas moléculas necesita más
energía así que observemos por qué por
qué el etanol tiene un punto de
ebullición elevado si les muestro dos
moléculas de etanol
interactuando aquí está una molécula de
etanol y continuemos
dibujando otra molécula de etanol por
aquí
y si pensamos en el enlace de oxígeno
con hidrógeno sé que es un enlace
covalente polarizado sé que hay una gran
diferencia en electrónica tividad entre
el oxígeno y el hidrógeno el oxígeno es
mucho más electro negativo lo que
significa que los electrones entre el
enlace del oxígeno y el hidrógeno van a
estar mucho más cerca al átomo de
oxígeno dándole al átomo de oxígeno una
carga parcialmente negativa por lo que
estos electrones entre el enlace del
oxígeno con el hidrógeno van a alejarse
del hidrógeno y el hidrógeno va a perder
un poco de densidad de electrones
dejándolo relativamente positivo dándole
una carga parcialmente positiva y pasa
lo mismo en la otra molécula de etanol
carga parcialmente negativa en el
oxígeno carga parcialmente positiva en
el hidrógeno y sabemos qué cargas
opuestas se atraen así que la carga
parcialmente positiva del hidrógeno es
atraída a la carga parcialmente negativa
del oxígeno y hay una fuerte fuerza
inter molecular que mantiene a esas dos
moléculas unidas y esos por supuesto son
los enlaces de hidrógeno así que hay
enlaces de hidrógeno
pero
entre moléculas de alcohol enlaces de
hidrógeno los enlaces de hidrógeno son
la fuerza internos le cular más fuerte
es relativamente difícil separar esas
dos moléculas requiere mucha energía
requiere mucho calor y es por eso que el
punto de ebullición del etanol es mucho
mayor que el punto de ebullición del
etano y eso también afecta el estado de
la materia
qué pasa con la solubilidad el etanol es
soluble en agua por supuesto que lo es y
se debe a los enlaces de hidrógeno una
vez más así que si dibujamos una
molécula de agua aquí
así que la molécula de agua está
polarizada en la misma forma en la que
está la molécula de alcohol así que el
hidrógeno es parcialmente positivo y el
oxígeno justo aquí es parcialmente
negativo y una vez más las cargas
supuestas se atraen el hidrógeno es
atraído a este oxígeno de aquí y debido
a los enlaces de hidrógeno hay
interacción entre la molécula de agua y
la molécula de alcohol
la molécula de agua es polar así que si
quieres pensarlo en términos de
polaridad debido a la diferencia en
electrónica tividad el agua es una
molécula polar el etanol es una molécula
polar también por lo que estas dos
moléculas serán solubles entre ellas así
que si veo a la estructura del etanol la
razón por la cual es soluble en agua es
por ésta
porción
de la molécula
este grupo hidroxilo este h son las
diferencias en electrónica tividad las
que permiten los enlaces de hidrógeno
esta porción de la molécula es la
porción polar de la molécula y esta
parte de la molécula es la porción que
ama el agua la razón por la que es
soluble así que se llama el agua vamos a
decir que es
pero
field y con hidro significa agua físico
significa amor hidrofílico
esta porción de aquí en la izquierda
esto es más del tipo alcano con un
ambiente
volar por lo que esta parte de la
molécula le tiene miedo al agua así que
es
y terror
pica
por lo que tenemos la porción
hidrofóbica de nuestra molécula de
alcohol tenemos nuestra porción
hidrofílica de la molécula de alcohol y
ahora sabemos que una molécula no polar
no se disolverá en una polar pero
siempre y cuando tengamos un número
relativamente pequeño de átomos de
carbono en nuestro grupo alquiló el
grupo h es suficiente y es
suficientemente polar para que el
alcohol sea soluble en agua ahora si
tienes un gran número de átomos de
carbono tu molecular es más no polar que
polar por lo que los alcoholes dejarán
de ser solubles en agua si tienen muchos
átomos de carbono en ellos
ahora veamos la preparación de alcohol
si dos así que veamos al alcohol
aquí tenemos nuestro alcohol
y si hacemos reaccionar nuestro alcohol
con una base fuerte así que aquí tenemos
un par de electrones libres y una carga
formal de menos 1 así que tenemos una
base fuerte aquí y nuestra base fuerte
va a tomar este protón y dejará
estos electrones atrás en este oxígeno
así que ahora tenemos ahora tenemos un
oxígeno que solía tener dos pares libres
de electrones y ahora tiene tres pares
libres lo que le da una carga formal de
menos 1
y la base la base va a formar un enlace
con este protón de esta manera así que
esta es una reacción ácido base
si hacemos reaccionar un alcohol con una
base fuerte la de aquí es una base
fuerte
vamos a formar la base con jugada a un
alcohol que es llamada al cocido por lo
que esto es unión
con sido
justo aquí esta es una propiedad química
de los alcoholes ellos se separan si
utilizas una base suficientemente fuerte
y la base conjugada con un alcohol es
llamada al cocido
veamos un ejemplo tenemos un
etanol
aquí tengo mi molécula de etanol íbamos
a hacer reaccionar eso con una base
fuerte como hidruro de sodio es n
h enea con más h con 2 y el hidrógeno
con 2 electrones alrededor de él lo que
lo hace unión negativamente cargado eso
se llama el guión y duro así que tenemos
la porción base el hidrógeno
negativamente cargado va a funcionar
como una base va a tomar
estos dos electrones
a tomar ese protón justo ahí el protón
en los alcoholes es el del hidrógeno y
los electrones de aquí van a acercarse
al oxígeno así
por lo que vamos a obtener como producto
una el cocido con tres pares libres de
electrones alrededor dándole una carga
formal
- solo
el sodio está flotando alrededor cargado
positivamente así que va a interactuar
electrostática mente y únicamente con
nuestro guión de alcohol sido y el guión
y duro tomó el protón por lo que ambos
hidrógeno se combinaron para formar gas
de hidrógeno lo que se desprende de la
solución la formación de gas de
hidrógeno va a observarse en esta
reacción y así es como formas los sal
cox y dos esta molécula es llamada el
óxido de sodio por lo que tenemos el
tóxico de sodio aquí en la derecha
tú sí no
solo tío
la cual es una base relativamente fuerte
usada en muchas reacciones de química
orgánica y ya que usamos una base fuerte
para formar la usamos hidruro de sodio
por aquí
y
duro
d
sodio
para formar esa molécula partiendo del
etanol y hay otra manera de formar al
cox y 2 así que veamos una manera
genérica de formar al cox y 2 a partir
del grupo 1 de metales alcalinos así que
aquí tenemos
nuestro
alcohol
justo así y si hacemos reaccionar
nuestro alcohol con nuestro metal del
grupo 1 con un metal alcalino aquellos
que tienen un electrón de valencia están
en el grupo 1 en la tabla periódica como
litio o sodio o potasio
vamos a formar un alcohol sido así que
vamos a formar
veamos
tres pares libres de electrones y una
carga formal de menos 1 y el mecanismo
es que el metal va a donar su electrón
de valencia dejando una carga de más 1
por lo que va a interactuar con tu
alcock sido de esta manera y esto
también desprende gas de hidrógeno esta
es la reacción general así que hagamos
un ejemplo donde reaccionemos usemos
usemos ciclohexano así que vamos a
reaccionar
ciclo hexano
con sodio así que vamos dibujemos la
molécula ciclohexano así porque quiero
mostrar un poco del mecanismo
así que dibujemos la así
pongamos los dos pares libres de
electrones en el oxígeno y el metal
sodio
tiene un electrón de valencia así
así que si pensamos en lo que sucede
él subió va a donar su electrón de
valencia muy fácil porque de esa manera
tendrá la configuración estable de un
gas noble así que el primer paso del
mecanismo es la donación de estos
electrones de valencia voy a mostrar el
movimiento de uno de los electrones por
lo que usaremos esta flecha de media
cabeza y vamos a utilizar una flecha de
doble cabeza para mostrar el movimiento
de esos dos electrones hacia el oxígeno
continuamos dibujando lo que tenemos
ahora tenemos nuestro anillo de
ciclohexano
ahora tenemos
es pares libres de electrones en el
oxígeno lo que lo carga negativamente y
el sodio donoso electrón de valencia por
lo que ahora
tiene una carga de más 1 así que va a
interactuar con ese oxígeno cargado
negativamente y qué pasa con el
hidrógeno el hidrógeno el hidrógeno de
ahí va a tomar un electrón así que
tenemos al hidrógeno con un electrón
alrededor de él eso es extremadamente
reactivo cuando dos de los átomos de
hidrógeno se acercan por supuesto que
van a reaccionar
y compartir sus electrones para formar
gas de hidrógeno así que puedo dibujarlo
de esta manera
ahí es donde están los dos electrones
los dos electrones están ahí uno para un
hidrógeno y el otro para el otro
hidrógeno por lo que en esta reacción
también se producirá gas de hidrógeno
este fue un resumen de las propiedades
físicas y también la preparación de
iones al cox y 2